those skyrocketing housing prices in las
vegas have come to a brief halt after
more than a year of record highs
victoria saha explains what this means
if you're looking to buy or don't plan
to sell i love the house that i bought
and i can call it my own you know mine
and my family we own this home now
maxine silva is a first-time homeowner
she took advantage of the record high
housing prices finally coming to a halt
once my lender was able to show me what
the monthly payments would be i would
say yeah i can do that for less than two
thousand dollars a month silva was able
to get the keys to her 380 thousand
dollar home in the popular southwest
valley buyers that have a thousand to
three thousand bucks saved up good
chance that you can go and purchase a
property cheaper than you can rent a
house for right now lender andrew levitt
says over the past year it was hard to
find a house out of state buyers offered
cash and over bid preventing first-time
buyers and those with approved loans
from even getting a chance but the
market is changing some are selling the
upgrades some are selling the downsize
some are just pulling out the equity in
general and going into a different state
right now the hot zip codes in the
valley are henderson and summerlin with
houses averaging about 450 thousand
dollars but leave it says the total
value shouldn't scare you look at how
much you can spend monthly to your
surprise you probably can afford it
victoria saha 8 news now
this is good news for current homeowners
too you may want to consider refinancing
and if your house is paid for you could
invest in a second one